so thank you everybody for joining us
today for this webinar I will present a
short summary of the new guard pea
business strategy this strategy has been
discussed with the board of directors of
BART guard P fairly recently just in our
last board meeting this month and has
been approved by our board of directors
however the full business plan will be
launched in in October during the World
Health Summit so what you will really
see here is a top-level perspective of
the strategy and obviously the the
reason one reason why we're doing this
webinars to also get some some input
from you in the external environment so
we very much welcome your questions as
well I will start with a very general
slide really identifying why
antimicrobial resistance is there is a
it's a global issue in this currently is
a global crisis and we believe it is a
threat to public health and has been
noted it is also a threat to agenda 2030
the sustainable development grows and is
widely seen as a risk in achieving
universal health coverage as well as a
health security issue in its own right
but of course the impact of AMR goes
beyond health there is direct impact on
poverty on trade obviously on healthcare
costs but also on livestock or output
considering the one health dimension of
antimicrobial resistance and what you
can see in this slide is really all the
different areas for instance where
antimicrobial resistance will impact on
the sustainable development goals I
think for all of us in this audience
it's very important that we emphasize
these what I would say cross-sectoral
impact of what is becoming a very
important issue of course when we then
look at and in a more narrow perspective
in the research and development
landscape and particularly when we talk
about research and development for new
therapeutics there are several aspects
that have really led to our current
situation where we see a highly
unfavorable environment and I'm saying
that as an understatement
and not in fact that is actually due to
to multiple factors on the one hand we
have growing public health needs and in
fact we have multiple indications needs
and populations that we have to address
we have very clear access gaps when we
talk about old and new antibiotics we
have a fragile pipeline and that really
is to a very large degree due to the
market failures there and of course
there is an issue around financing both
for research and development and for
access and sustainable use so all of
these factors are really contributing to
a very complex picture and unfortunately
to reason why organizations like God P
do need to exist just a little bit about
us God P facts and figures we are as
Jennifer mentioned an independent
foundation we were we are actually
registered in Switzerland and we are
currently in the process of seeking
International Organization status we
have been co-founded by the World Health
Organization is part of the global
action plan and the drugs for neglected
diseases initiative and we have now set
up a scientific advisory board and a
board of directors as part of the
governance structures God P has already
started operational activities so just
looking at least from the research and
development side we are of course
working on a first and class antibiotic
that's now entering phase three we have
four recovered antibiotics in different
phases of development we have several
new chemical entities that we are now
under discussions with potential biotech
companies we have started some very
small early-stage R&D activities so we
are currently screening for libraries
for antibiotic activity and we have
acted today conducted completed three
clinical studies clinical trials so we
are in the process of actually
continuing to fundraise for our current
and future activities and to say we are
largely a government-funded organization
at present and as you can see in the
photo there is now actually a team
behind garde P as well as a very
network of partners that also
significant important in executing the
operations of God P so God P does in for
us does represent a very unique approach
in addressing AMR and trying to address
this issue of the R&D pipeline and and
really the failures that we're seeing in
how and how I think different sectors
can can accelerate the development of
new therapeutics from our perspective
God P takes a very strong public health
are in the perspective we are therefore
here to address global health priorities
incorporating the needs also of
developing countries as well as
developed countries our principle is
that we work from any point entry point
but wherever we start we go all the way
through registration and into access and
any given one of our projects we are
engaging with multiple different actors
in a collaborative approach we are also
here to target important indications
that are less likely to develop be
developed by other actors and also
ensure that new antibiotics developed
our affordable and available in high
burden countries and I think it's
through this that we feel that we can
best address the issue around the SDGs
and also help to meet at the cup whu-oh
to meet the global action plan against
amma we have now as part of a new
business strategy formulated a new
vision and mission which is presented
here in the slides all infections are
treatable for everyone everywhere and
really our mission is to bring together
the public and private sectors to
develop and deliver new treatments for
bacterial infections addressing the
public health impact of antibiotic
resistance so really this is really to
emphasize that we are here to develop
and to deliver we are going to focus on
unlikely on late stage R&D going into
access our modus operandi is to work
with the bring together the public and
the private sector considering that a
lot of the innovation
is largely in the private sector and
that we believe in developing strong
actual partnerships particularly with
the pharmaceutical and biotechnology
industries so this is really a kind of
over your snapshot of God P and of
course within our partnerships beyond
our private sector partners we are
incorporating academia civil society
governments and of course our funders of
course as I mentioned EE Cho has been
very instrumental in helping to set up
God P and we have a very close
collaboration with the World Health
Organization WTO plays an extremely
important role in the response global
response against antimicrobial
resistance they are part of the
tripartite and of course many of you may
be familiar of the interagency
coordination group that has come up with
very clear recommendations and W chose
really playing an important role there
EE chose really working to do the
priority setting provide technical input
it convenes international experts and
meetings for us it is there to provide
the global development and stewardship
framework particularly around access it
is helped guard key to mobilize
political support of member states and
it's really helped to bring in guard P
and not just God P but AMR in general
into the g20 g7 and other international
fora and of course on a day to day basis
we are interacting with multiple
departments within wo of course the
newly created AMR division which is led
by the new assistant director-general
dr. Han and bulky the disease
departments such as the sexual
reproductive health department and of
course the medicines essential medicines
programs that plays a very important
role in health policy and access and of
course we also work with the the
regional and country offices of WH o so
our new business strategy is really
framed around commitment of what we can
deliver between 2020 and 2025 so we have
launched a new 5 bi
twenty-five strategy where we are
committed to develop and deliver five
new treatments to address antibiotic
resistant infections by 2025 and to give
you an example what kind of treatments
are we aiming to develop of course there
will be based on the WTO priority
pathogen list so they could include for
instance treatments for carbapenem
resistant senator boxer infections or
carbapenem resistant anterior bacteria
say infections but also we are looking
at specific diseases and indications as
well so this will include secchi
transmitted infections and of course we
are focusing also not just on adult
populations but also on children and and
pediatric and neonatal populations so we
are trying to take a kind of three lens
approach with the pathogens the
populations and of course specific
indications as well and we will be
focused on developing assets in
late-stage clinical development and
working on accelerating their access as
well now obviously to achieve this even
if we are relying on other entities and
other organizations and funders who will
be providing and funding a lot of these
projects as well as well as funding from
the private sector
we still believe we need significant
financial resources to achieve this five
by 25 goal so we are really calling to
to raise 500 million to accelerate the
development and delivery of these five
new treatments by 2025 and we have
already started an active engagement to
achieve this objective so a little bit
about how God P works we have our vision
and mission and within our mission we
have the different strategic pillars of
god p and we have four strategic pillars
that we have developed as part of our
new business strategy but in fact to be
honest this is already I would say the
current modus operandi of God P so
probably the more well the more
well-known a pillar is what we do around
research and development where we are
dressed in global health needs in the
R&D pillar we have both in some in-house
expertise as well as
network of partners and service
providers who work closely with us as
well we focus on clinical and
pharmaceutical development and we will
work both on regulatory and public
health trials and work towards label
expansion as well as evidence generation
for optimum implementation and of course
this this will mean that we will require
significant resources because the
downstream part is really where one
needs significant resources to conduct
these activities we will also maintain a
small number of projects in the
discovery and exploratory phase and of
course we are aim to work very closely
with other initiatives such as karbix
because ultimately we are here to also
work in taking forward I think promising
candidates coming out of the of the
karbix pipeline as well the second
pillar is based around our portfolio
management and in a way this is really
trying to ensure that we can coordinate
and move forward key drugs of Public
Health value within a what we call a
public health portfolio so this within
this portfolio we are committed to build
invest and Co develop with our private
sector partners
we are willing to provide both in-kind
and direct contributions to them in
return for contact all returns around
access of which I will mention more of
that later and of course what we're
trying to ensure is that we have the
freedom and rights to develop for public
health indications as well as register
and deliver these tools in high burden
countries and specific target
populations the third pillar is key
because we are a partnership and we work
through a partnership model so this bill
is really concerning partnerships and
networks and they are really all the
multiple different entities that we have
already got together with and that we
hope to also partner in the future to
help us really deliver on our mission
so within us as the guard P team we want
to stay as a fairly lean team and what
we really intend to do is work directly
in collaboration and partnerships with a
range of different actors
to help us execute our mission and
through doing this we also hope
therefore and continue to enrich the R&D
ecosystem in the drug development space
we hope to strengthen clinical trial
networks incorporating high burden
countries for instance and we also want
to build these strategic partnerships
that are going to be directly involved
in accelerating and delivering on R&D
programs and a key part of what we will
do is really bring together the public
and and private sector in in a
partnership model and the last pillar
last but not least is really around
sustainable access this will of course
be focused on our portfolio of drugs
that we have but there are different
things that we are intending to look at
such as how can we accelerate a global
regulatory approach and ensure access in
a wide range of countries and some of
you may be familiar of a recent
publication that showed that in fact due
to a variety of different factors many
of the new antibiotics that were being
coming onto the market were registered
in a very small number of countries we
also intend to work on how we can look
at things like cost of goods and
streamlining manufacturing and really
ensuring that we have a sustainable
supply really linking with third parties
including antibiotic manufacturers and
generic companies the third aspect is
around reimbursement models and linked
to that also procurement strategies we
feel both aspects are very important to
address I think if we don't look at
reimbursement we are going to run into
significant problems around the long
term sustainable access of these
antibiotics and I think this is very
much fitting into also W Joe's own
strategy around fair pricing so it is
something that we will need to look at
for the portfolio drugs that we are
working at and we are committed to work
with our private sector partners as well
as governments on this I think in
procurement there's much that has been
done in the global health space we feel
there are some opportunities to really
look at how procurement can be
approached to really ensure that for
instance we can look at much more
predictable demand we can accelerate
access
and we can also ensure that the approach
on how antibiotics are introduced and
how sales are approached are different
so I think we we do feel that we do need
to look at and engage with other global
health actors and see how we can
advocate for others to be involved and
potentially do interventions both for
PETA potentially a small number of old
and new antibiotics and particularly to
focus on procurement for for high burden
countries when we look at policy and
guidelines for us we feel this is
absolutely essential to not just ensure
access but appropriate use and therefore
stewardship so God P is committed
towards engaging two - both directly and
indirectly support studies and evidence
generation that will inform and guide
policy and use and this is often an
overlooked piece particularly post
registration but can be important in
better determining the use of of a new
antibiotic that's coming onto the market
and last not least or obviously we are
going to be looking at how we can
support in and out licensing strategies
and this is absolutely critical to look
at sustainable manufacturing and supply
of antibiotics in different regions of
the world and then cutting across that
is the work we're going to do around
financing and of course what we have to
do as an organization to developed to
ensure we can deliver on these strategic
pillars as well as having the
transparent and open governance that
will make us you know and Trust able
partner to engage in both the public and
private sector and this slide really
goes into a little bit more granularity
on on the previous slide so looking at
how we bridge this gap between R&D and
access and look looking at how we
utilize the partnership model to do this
starting at the bottom we are targeting
public health needs and through that
once we have done that we're including
with other actors such as probably H oh
we start to build a public health
portfolio and then conduct or finance
our and approve
to direct or ink on investments and
secure fordable access through
negotiated partnerships and then work
through the process with our partners
and work through that through
registration and facilitating policy
guidelines use out licensing strategies
and how we can then support rollout of
new treatments and to do this we will
leverage both the public and private are
in the ecosystem and you there's a range
of different actors that may be involved
in any specific individual project that
we are engaged in with the objective of
ultimately accelerating access to all in
need practically speaking what is our
operations look like obviously we have a
small number of discovery and
exploratory program exploratory work and
in the middle piece is really about
asset evaluation so what are the key
assets out there that we can identify
and then engage in in a significant
manner in the clinical development stage
and I will really say clinical and
pharmaceutical development because we
are also actively engaging with partners
on for instance CMC and pharmaceutical
development we have four programs for
the late stage development such as the
first program is on sexually transmitted
infections the second and third is on
neonatal sepsis and also on accelerating
the development of pediatric antibiotics
particularly new chemical entities in
the pipeline how we can accelerate the
pediatric studies and pediatric
indications and lastly this is a new
program that we will be commencing in
our new business plan a program on adult
serious gram-negative bacteria
infections so here we will be engaging
with companies to to really see how we
can support them in their late stage
clinical development to facilitate
registration but also beyond that well
how we can expand indications how we can
also do the additional public health
cause that will be critical for policy
guidelines use
and ultimately also things like
reimbursement so I think you know these
are these are there's a lot of technical
aspects that one has to cover here and
we obviously will need to carefully
choose and build our portfolio to
deliver on these programs and cutting
across our R&D programs our scientific
affairs including the revive project
that is really extremely important in in
helping us do our outreach to provide
education knowledge knowledge sharing so
what does building successful
partnerships with the private sector
look like this slide is really a very
top level slide and I would like to make
it very clear that no we don't have a
cut and paste agreement with companies
and even within a company we may have
different agreements for different drug
development projects but broadly
speaking we are willing to provide R&D
sponsorship including what we can we
take you on sponsored clinical trials
and also on CMC development and also
provide our in-house expertise so
providing that as also as an in-kind
support we also provide access to the
guard P Network including a network we
are starting to really support in high
burden countries and then also engage in
post regulatory activities as I
mentioned such as space for trials and I
think importantly we can provide this
R&D sponsorship and fund all of the
trials but we can also provide upfront
funding for specific entities who are
already engaged in sponsoring their own
activities but of course this will have
to be carefully crafted and have to be
milestone driven and so this is really
going to depend on a company by company
basis on a project-by-project basis it
will depend on what you and the
companies have in terms of your own
in-house expertise your own
infrastructure your own resources
who else you're partnering with who are
your service providers what commitments
you have already made to other investors
and on the flip side of the coin you
know where your gaps and so we will
tailor make an agreement to best fit
that scenario
of course we will have requests on our
side so we will need to have some
oversight on what you are doing this
could be set up through things like
joint steering committees for instance
and through require reporting mechanisms
we will need to obviously agree on a
common Rd and access strategy that's a
given because we want we CR ourselves as
a partner and so clear we need to
clearly knew and you see that what are
realistic and achievable stewardship and
access commitments that we can make we
can also look at exclusive licenses in
priority countries particularly high
burden developing countries as an
example of that where we know that
marketing the product may be a struggle
for certain companies so this is
something that we are willing to take on
and we we will of course discuss things
like royalties on sales to support
access in these high burden settings as
well so we as ourselves are also
committed to trying and finding you know
multiple and sustainable financing
mechanisms for our programs and projects
and of course we do have to ensure
affordability globally but also of
course for for developing countries this
will be an issue and I of course very
much regret that we have to put in this
last issue but we do indeed have to
think about how in the deal structure we
will deal with things like bankruptcy
and change of control as well so these
are things that I think we can manage we
can do and we are already engaged in
with a few private sector entities to
discuss it so this is not set in stone
this is going to be tailor-made we are
realistic on what we ask because it will
be tied to what we put in so clearly the
more we put in the more we will ask back
but I think for all of you who are
working in this space this is this is a
very reasonable approach so then going
to the next slide which really talks
about the collaborative partnership
model as you can see there are many
different sectors one has to engage in
even on an individual drug development
project this can provide some complexity
in terms of managing all these
relationships and this is something as
in god P that we have experienced as
individuals do
but we feel these the this kind of
complex relationships are of course
essential in doing approaching drug
development from from an international
perspective in trying to address global
health needs and we will work largely as
a virtual organization through these
partnerships and and really will seek to
ensure multi stakeholder collaborations
where they are relevant we can be
involved in actively driving programs
and another other areas where that's
less appropriate because of the I think
the the resources of the entity were
partnering with this can be more fun
being direction and support and of
course we have in-house capabilities as
well as a network of experts and and
partners that will be involved in our in
our R&D programs so what does access
look like to us there are different
aspects that we are starting to look at
in Access ranging from procurement to
reimbursement to sow some strategies
policy use regulatory licensing but we
are not necessarily going to be fully
involved in all these different spaces
there can be light levels of engagement
on one side to heavy levels of
engagement and we may advocate or
facilitate or implement or do all three
and so that will probably be based more
on the individual program project and
partnership we form but clearly we feel
that we will probably be more involved
on things like working on CMC cost of
goods on the network networking in
partnership building on policy in use on
expanding global registration and where
relevant on on supporting in and out
licensing as well and there are other
areas where we we will need to play a
supportive role and and/or facilitator
role and would emphasize that of course
we are also engaged with whu-oh who are
really involved in policy making so our
role issue of generate the evidence
WTO's role is to set policy and
guidelines so just to make sure that
there's no confusion between those those
two
Spex